[Musique]
cette semaine à enquête le canada est il
devenu un paradis pour la mafia canada
is a good place to be le canada est un
bon endroit pour la mafia au canada les
risques de poursuites et
d'emprisonnement sont moindres
qu'ailleurs et toronto en quartier
général
ça fait plus de dix ans que nous disons
canadiens de faire attention parce que
la haine drang l'état est très présente
au canada surtout à toroguhé le montre
peut-être quand la police italienne
critique sévèrement les autorités
canadiennes dans sa lutte contre la
mafia
si le noir anti association mafieuse
celui conquis au canada on en a pas il
n'a même pas une loi sur les
associations mafieuses
c'est pas sérieux mais tu as passé
[Musique]
à
bienvenue en quête le rôle que joue la
mafia est plus que jamais dans
l'actualité avec les témoignages qu'on a
entendu à la commission charbonneau et
on risque d'en entendre encore plus
parler avec la libération dans les
prochains jours
de vito rizzuto que fera t-il se vengera
t-il chose certaine le monde interlope
au canada a beaucoup changé depuis sa
condamnation la mafia sicilienne a perdu
de son lustre au profit de la mafia
calabraise la n'drangheta la plus
puissante au monde
l'andra ngata est plus visible au québec
mais règne en ontario surtout à toronto
dans notre enquête de sept semaines
réalisé en collaboration avec le toronto
star plusieurs affirment que landrin
guetta est passé maître dans l'art de
corrompre les milieux d'affaires et
politique
et si toronto était plus corrompus que
montréal enquête sur le rôle au canada
de la n'dranghetta l'autre mafia guetta
est une des organisations criminelles
les plus puissants moment là
[Musique]
c'est le plus grand territoire ici aussi
des morts il ya 96 local criminelle à
toronto il y en a neuf en tout cas la
'ndrangheta est un état dans l'état
à l'instar de talia elles contrôlent
tout le territoire 365 jours par année
[Musique]
attention car il faut toujours prendre
au sérieux les crimes organisés du
canada est très liée à la drogue et à
habitalys les mêmes familles qui sont
actives en italie ne sont aussi à
toronto
quand vous voyez l'impact économique et
la corruption politique du crime
organisé
c'est aussi dévastateur que le
terrorisme
[Musique]
c'est ici dans la tranquillité des
montagnes des planes et des villages
côtiers de la calabre que la mafia la
plus puissante du monde contrôler une
partie des activités du crime organisé
au canada surtout en ontario
elle se nomme la haine dring et à un
mood syrie dieu grec qui signifie homme
courageux et vaillants cette mafia s'est
fait connaître dans les années 70 et 80
par ces enlèvements spectaculaires comme
ce tweet qu'en 1973 pour deux petits
fils du milliardaire jean paul getty
caché pendant cinq mois dans les
montagnes de la calabre un enlèvement
qui file à manchettes partout dans le
monde pour convaincre getty de leur
verser une rançon les ravisseurs ont
fait parvenir un journal de rome
une enveloppe contenant une oreille de
gentil fils
des enfants même obtenu 3 millions de
dollars contre la libération de prague
et y c'est avec ce genre de coup d'éclat
que landrin guetta s'est enrichie pour
par la suite se convertir dans le trafic
de drogue
malgré sa puissance et sa richesse cette
organisation reste fortement ancré dans
la tradition locale de la calabre
rares sont les images où l'on voit ses
dirigeants réunis ensemble la
n'dranghetta est une organisation encore
plus discrète que la cosa nostra
sicilienne
mais tout aussi violente même dans ses
chansons
palmer
photo là bas
m
[Musique]
la n'dranghetta est un état dans l'état
en calabre
c'est une mafia extrêmement bien
organisés dans un village des montagnes
calabraise ses dirigeants ont même fait
construire le réseau complexe de tunnels
pour leur permettre de se cacher ou de
s'enfuir lors des rafles policières
contrairement à la cosa nostra
sicilienne la n'dranghetta est presque
impossible à infiltrer avec sa structure
horizontale et l'ailier de sang une
essentielle chez vous et les membres de
l'organisation et que vous décidiez de
témoigner contre un autre membre
essentiellement vous trahissez votre
propre frère votre mère ou votre père
ce qui nous rend la tâche très difficile
this very difficult l'omerta est quasi
complète mais pour une des rares fois la
police italienne a réussi à finir il ya
quelques années une rencontre entre ses
plus hauts dirigeants
grâce à ces images on peut assister au
rituel sacré des dangereux mafieux de
landing et à chaque année sous la statue
de la madone dans le petit village san
luca se tient le criminel soit le
regroupement des chefs de chacun des
clans d'organisation est qu un certain
du canada
si les nouveaux chers sont choisis des
rôles sont déterminés et les priorités
pour l'année suivante sont était
grenoble
ou bien at il assuré
la 'ndrangheta compte 10000 membres à
travers le monde
son chiffre d'affaires atteint les 60
milliards de dollars annuellement 3 % du
pib de toute l'italie grâce notamment au
monopole sur le trafic de la cocaïne en
europe mais de plus en plus la
'ndrangheta est présente dans l'économie
légale en recyclant l'argent provenant
de la drogue
ces dirigeants contrôle entre autres
l'industrie de la construction dans
plusieurs régions d'italie
[Musique]
j'ai payé entre 1981 et 2002 finale de
mai et doit en tout vous avez dit combi
de 3 millions de dollars chaque mois
l'entrepreneur gaetano safiote s'ils
recevaient la visite de mafieux
calabrais pour leur remettre de grosses
liasses d'argent pour payer son pidjot
un jour il en a eu assez et a décidé de
filmer à leur insu les hommes qui menait
de collecter pour par la suite les
dénoncer à la police
ce système du pizzo dans la construction
a été exportée en amérique du nord
notamment au québec où des entrepreneurs
les payer leur dû au quartier général
des régies tôt le condamne à tous ici
tout le monde doit payer le pizzo alain
gayda ce n'est pas seulement pour des
raisons économiques mais aussi pour nous
faire comprendre qui est le vrai patron
qui grâce à sa collaboration avec la
police gaitan aux safiots qui a fait
emprisonner près de cent mafieux mais il
le paie très cher
il nous a montré la chute radicale de
son chiffre d'affaires jour au lendemain
on a incendié ces camions et il crée en
permanence un attentat contre lui ou sa
famille et c'est pas une question de
courage
j'ai peur de me faire tuer ils ont fait
sauter mais j'avais davantage peur au
lieu d'enseigner les bonnes valeurs d'un
an fils il aurait fallu que je lui
montre à qui il doit donner de la gaita
nous ne regrette rien même s'il doit
vivre escorté par des gardes du corps 24
heures sur 24
aujourd'hui je suis un homme libre
autrefois je pensais que j'étais libre
et mais c'était une fausse liberté
keita novia quelques kilomètres d'un des
plus gros ports d'europe donnant sur la
méditerranée
la construction du port de djawad toro
s'est terminée dans les années 90
l'opération solar est mené conjointement
par la police italienne et américaine a
levé le voile sur le rôle de ce port au
coeur d'un vaste réseau de distribution
européen de cocaïne provenant du mexique
et de la colombie de leur petit village
de la calabre les mafieux de la
'ndrangheta sont ainsi devenus très
influent dans l'économie de plusieurs
régions en italie en blanchissant leur
narcodollars et ça c'est le
l'appartement de
deux postes de palerme ou tadao ou
cabines et un autre un fouet à la cma
fiore alberto nairas tiny a réalisé
plusieurs documentaires sur la mafia
on pense à la mafia et on pense toujours
à assassiner l'homicide eux laissant la
violence dans les rues et tout ça m'a la
mafia pour moi même aujourd'hui et
blanches la mafia cesser l'infiltration
dont dans les grand palais de la
politique c'est l'infiltration dans
l'économie sur l'infiltration dans dans
la société
comme québec l'industrie de la
construction et le secteur idéal pour le
blanchiment de l'argent provenant du
trafic de drogue
d'ailleurs c'est en partenariat avec des
calabrais que le clan dirige tout québec
a failli réussir à obtenir le contrat de
construction du pont de messine à
projette de 7 milliards et demi de
dollars qui finalement été annulé selon
les enquêtes policières une grande
partie des travaux de l'autoroute menant
au site
le pont devait être construite et
contrôlés dans la mafia calabraise comme
strates chance tous les contrats de
construction publiques ou privées sont
accordées à des compagnies liées à la
haine dernier tu as toujours toujours
toujours et son parti sont partout le
grand projet en italie katia lund règne
est actuellement si l'exposition
universelle de milan en 2015
les travaux ne sont même pas commencé
que la police est déjà sur les dames
avec ce qu'elle atteint dans les
conversations téléphoniques entre
mafieux c'est très intéressant écouter
les mafieux qu'il part de l'expo ils ne
sont pas aux recteurs les institutions
son art et à la région nord et à la
politique aurait tard les mafieux sont
là léger retrait alberto nairas dini a
obtenu les transcriptions de l'écouté
électronique des entrepreneurs liés à la
n'dranghetta ou en gros ils disent que
il faut s'organiser on a besoin d
501 pour l'expo il faut être prêt pour
l'export parce que beaucoup de contrats
vont animer il parle avec les
politiciens pour heures pour les mafieux
et ils disent que l'idéal la chose idéal
ce serait de lui faire faire le
directeur de l'ex pro le modus operendi
à milan pour blanchir l'argent sale à
travers les contrats de construction
ressemble à ce qui se fait ici lors des
appels d'offres publics la corruption
est présente tous les échelons de la
compagnie qui remporte la mise
ou sous traitants mafieux les appels
d'offres sont organisées selon les
besoins de l'entrepreneur qui doit
remporter la soumission et qu'ils soient
certains oui j pour être certain de
l'emporter
il doit payer quelqu'un ils payent les
fonctionnaires ou les politiciens qui
change gaitan ou saffioti l'entrepreneur
de calabre qui a dénoncé la n'dranghetta
ne participe pas aux appels d'offres
dans la région de milan
craignant de tomber dans les griffes de
la mafia il a ni ailleurs où les clans
mafieux calabrais sont très actifs
notamment canada je sais que les clan de
la 'ndrangheta ont des racines au canada
notamment à toronto et à montréal et joe
borg montréal
[Musique]
après la pause toronto plus infiltrées
par la mafia que montréal leur présence
est actuellement plus importante qu'au
québec parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'argent
[Musique]
cet homme au volant de sa voiture
blindée et directement sur la ligne de
feu dans la guerre contre la mafia en
italie comme l'était le juge giovanni
falcone et avant qu'ils ne soient tués
lors de ma tante en sicile en 1992
le sacrifice du juge falcone et est une
source d'inspiration pour nicola
gratteri procureur antimafia vedette qui
pourchasse sans relâche la n'dranghetta
est ce que il arrive parfois que
vous avez l'impression que vous allez
finir un peu comme falcon ligne est-ce
que des fois vous avez l'impression que
vos jours sont comptés
des fois j'ai pensé du match et malgré
tout vous continuez je continue parce
que je ne veux pas vivre comme un lâche
et je veux continuer à regarder dans les
yeux les gens qui me font confiance
[Musique]
malgré les nombreuses menaces qu'il a
reçues le procureur guéri conduit lui
même sa voiture mais il est escortée en
permanence par trois gardes du corps qui
le suivent par une voiture derrière il
doit toujours être en mouvement pour
éviter les embuscades
lorsque nous avons accompagné le
procureur grattieri en juin dernier il
se rendait en sicile pour prononcer une
conférence devant d'autres procureurs
dans le traversier reliant la calabre et
à la sicile ses gardes du corps ne le
lâche pas d'une semelle
je vis sous escorte depuis 1989
à l'époque les mafieux ont tiré sur la
maison méfiance et ensuite ils y ont
appelé pour me dire de ne pas m'épouser
car elle épouserait un homme mort
par la suite on a intercepté une
conversation dans une prison où on
disait qu'il fallait me tuer avec une
bombe mois ainsi que mes gardes du corps
parce que j'avais ruines et leurs rues
il y avait un jour on a intercepté une
autre conversation téléphonique où on
entendait un chef dire qu'il avait
acheté 15 kg d'explosifs pour me tuer
depuis ces années je fais toujours
attention la lutte d'une colle à gratter
riz contre la 'ndrangheta ne se limite
pas à la calabre dans l'anc est
criminelle à laquelle il a participé
un chapitre complet porte sur
l'infiltration de la n'dranghetta au
canada et la main la mafia toronto est
plus forte que celle de montréal pendant
longtemps au canada c'était le contraire
la mafia la plus puissante était à
montréal
il était dirigé par le calabrais vic
cotroni le crime organisé à toronto
était alors à ses pieds
[Musique]
mario latraverse dirige et à l'époque
les squats anti mafia k police de
montréal à toronto
il adhère et il ne dirigeait pas comme
il pouvait le juger au québec mais il y
avait un pourcentage des profits que
l'ontario faisons
mais l'ère des calabrais a pris fin avec
l'emprisonnement de frank cotroni la
mort de son frère vic et le meurtre de
pareloup violi l'aspirant parent par le
clan sicilien des rizzuto les signes est
incertain randonnée ont demandé à new
york
la permission de tuer par l'eau
new york avant de donner cette
permission l'heure
en fait une enquête ils ont envoyé deux
émissaires ici après discussions entre
eux
bâle ots en tuant vieux dit plus rien
n'empêchait les siciliens de prendre le
contrôle du crime organisé à montréal
une partie des calabrais se sont rangés
derrière eux les autres ont quitté pour
l'ontario surtout toronto plus riches
c'est là où discrètement la branche
canadienne de la 'ndrangheta calabraise
a pris son essor avec à sa tête le
groupe de 6 dernies en italie ce
procureur antimafia de la calabre suit
de près les activités de la n'dranghetta
au canada la partie frenchy céder le
canada et le canada français n'est pas
particulièrement infiltrée par la
n'dranghetta mais le canada anglais lui
laisse la double vie nous en avons
appris davantage sur son importance lors
d'une enquête que nous avons menée dans
les années 90 sur ce qu'on appelle le
groupe de six des morts sud est aussi
drôle
siderno petit village côtier de sud de
l'italie
un village en apparence sans histoire
[Musique]
mais c'est de là que proviennent des
clans mafieux les plus dangereux de la
calabre se sont implantées en ontario la
corruption là bas est endémique
l'arrestation que l'on voit ici est
celle de nul autre le maire du village
en 2010 alessandro fei au mini
soupçonnés d'entretenir des liens avec
la n'dranghetta il aurait agi comme
intermédiaire entre le clan comisso et
les neuf juges ontarienne il s'est rendu
à plusieurs reprises attentes de bo3 v
jumelles de 6 dernies la police
italienne soupçonne d'avoir profité de
sa visite pour rencontrer des contacts
de mafieux établie dans cette ville dans
un rapport d' enquête la police
italienne fait état de l'existence en
ontario de cette locales et ou clan de
la 'ndrangheta à toronto et de deux
atteint 2 b ça fait des années qu'on
enquête sur la banque d'état au canada
il ya des clones de l'organisation en
italie et à toronto
il y à des interfaces il y à un clan de
la 'ndrangheta assis terme en italie qui
est en lien avec un clan à toronto
mollahs qui est en lien avec un autre
clan à toronto les règles d'affiliation
est à faire à toronto sont les mêmes
qu'en italie les procureurs italiens
sont convaincus que la 'ndrangheta est
filtrée l'économie légale canadienne
surtout ontarienne pourrait blanchir une
partie de ces milliards provenant des
revenus de la cocaïne comme l'ont fait
les riches tout au québec et ailleurs
le canada est un état vierge
ils ont infiltré l'économie surtout la
construction précisément les secteurs de
l'excavation et du ciment le canada est
un lieu stratégique à cause de sa
proximité avec les états unis
c'est aussi un endroit important pour
leurs activités internationales comme le
trafic de drogue et le blanchiment
d'argent ou le logo du recyclage de la
nar
cet ancien officier de la grc benso
avait dirigé jusqu'en 2004 la lutte
contre le crime organisé en ontario on
lui doit entre autres l'arrestation
d'alfonso caruana le chef du puissant
clan des caruana contraire à qui vivait
calmement à woodbridge dans nord de
toronto
il est nullement surpris des résultats
des enquêtes italienne à son avis cela
démontre l'importance d'une infiltration
de la n'dranghetta dans l'économie
ontarienne et dans une déclaration choc
il affirme que la corruption qu'elle
engendre est au moins aussi pire en
ontario qu'au québec l'ontario a les
mêmes problèmes je l'amène corruption
les mêmes groupes criminels qu'au québec
mais s'ils sont beaucoup plus discrets
rybak alors les autres endroits n'ont
pas eu la même attention que québec a
dit tyson est ce que ça signifie qu'ils
sont moins actifs qu'ils ont moins et
filtrer l'ontario doutes quant au
contraire ils sont probablement plus
actif qu'au québec même soit venez pas
le seul à penser ainsi
antonio nicaso est un spécialiste de la
mafia qui a déjà été victime d'un
attentat alors qu'il vivait en calabre
il est établi depuis une quinzaine
d'années à toronto leur présence est
actuellement plus importante qu'au
québec parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'argent investi aussi l'entrant guetta
canadienne est étroitement liées à la
'ndrangheta italiennes sont très forts
mais demeure disque
la pieuvre de lâm dông et en ontario
surtout dans la région de toronto n'agit
pas seulement dans le milieu des
affaires des sources policières de la
région de toronto nous ont affirmé
qu'elle parvient aussi à corrompre les
politiciens andré cédilot se souvient
avoir assisté il ya quelques années un
événement bénéfice à toronto où étaient
présents des politiciens et des membres
associés à la haine dring état le chef
mafieux était présenté à mon contact est
là
le chef mafieux avait sa table à
quelques tables seulement de politique
au toronto et à la pause j'ai vu à ma
grande surprise le chef mafieux qui
parlait avec le politicien tantôt from
pour la déco l'infiltration passer par
des politiciens la police les personnes
oeuvrant dans le système judiciaire
jusqu'au manufacturier les politiciens
vraiment absurde humains parfois les
politiciens sont très naïf il ne se
méfie pas du danger
il serre des mains ils acceptent de
l'argent et après ils veulent être
pardonné quand vous regardez l'impact
économique la corruption politique par
le crime organisé est aussi dévastatrice
que le terrorisme absolument le grand
patron actuel dans la lutte contre le
crime organisé au canada
l'inspecteur wayne jacquard de la grc
dit ne pas être en mesure de déterminer
laquelle des deux provinces le québec
l'ontario et la plus infiltrées par la
mafia non plus l'étendue de la
corruption que ses activités en jambes
de la part de la grc iucn renseignements
que j'ai qui demande que cette
infiltration était faite aux purs au
niveau du
ona mayer on sait que c'est une méthode
opération qu'ils ont néanmoins est ce
que l'économie est touchée par le crime
organisé
oui l'économie est touchée par être
immunisé nos poches ce même non pas
seulement notariaux derrière après la
pause des individus recherchés par la
police italienne qui vivent
confortablement
toronto le canada n'a pas de loi
antimafia être membre d'une organisation
criminelle n'est pas un crime au canada
[Musique]
comme plusieurs autres mafieux de la
calabre cette dame je suis la justice
italienne pour se réfugier dans la
grande région de toronto en 2004
[Musique]
antonio comisso était à la tête d'un des
clans les plus puissants de la calabre
lors de sa fuite il venait d'être
condamné à 10 ans prison pour complot
pour meurtre trafic de drogue et d'armes
et corruption ayant obtenu un statut de
résident permanent dans les années 70 il
est entré au canada en montrant son
propre passeport
il a obtenu par la suite un permis de
conduire en règle une carte d'assurance
maladie
ils vivaient dans cette résidence en
banlieue de toronto
sans être inquiétés jusqu'à ce que la
police italienne obtienne son
extradition un an plus tard
cette mère a sauvé l'honneur des jo une
vraie guerre c'est normal nous sommes en
guerre
à la guerre comme à la guerre john
bellavia est un spécialiste du
blanchiment d'argent rang pour la police
italienne anti mafia
c'est quoi ça c'est l'histoire des papas
les aristos pour lui le canada est un
véritable paradis pour les mafieux avec
ses lois beaucoup moins sévère que celle
d'alien notamment pour contrer le
blanchiment d'argent et le problème à
des tout est pas aisé causer des grands
pays qui ont beaucoup de matières
premières qui sont peu peuplées et qui
ont un grand potentiel de développement
à méthane sont ciblés par les
organisations criminelles
keystone auch est aidé à leur mine hâlée
antonio comisso est un des rares à avoir
été extradé ces dernières années par le
canada pour qu'on jette en prison en
italie
[Musique]
si on se fie aux rapports des enquêtes
de la police italienne
le canada est devenu un véritable refuge
pour des mafieux qui veulent échapper à
la justice italienne
l' enquête criminelle a identifié une
trentaine de résidents d'anciens
résidents canadiens qui ont un lien avec
la mafia
parmi eux une vingtaine vivent toujours
au canada selon nos recherches la moitié
d'entre eux sont visés par des mandats
d'arrestation italien masi vivent
paisiblement en ontario sans être
inquiété huit ont été arrêtés alors
qu'ils se trouvaient en territoire
italien
canada accueille brest b le canada est
un bon endroit pour nom la fia au canada
les risques de poursuites et
d'emprisonnement sont moindres
qu'ailleurs
le canada n'a pas de lois anti-mafia
être membre d'une organisation
criminelle n'est pas un crime en italie
le clan dame tonio commis sous avait
l'habitude de tenir ses réunions chaque
rata siderno dans la buanderie du centre
commercial appartenant à giuseppe son
frère il était surnommé le maître il a
été condamné l'an dernier à 14 ans de
prison
pour arriver à ce résultat la police
italienne a réussi un coup d'éclat en
plaçant dans la buanderie des
microphones un peu comme l'avait fait
les policiers de la grc en installant
des caméras au consenza dans l'est de
montréal
dans une conversation impliquant des
mafieux vivant au canada en visite à
siderno on parle souvent de toronto dans
l'extrait suivant il est question des
méthodes de surveillance de la police et
le fait que certains reportages ont
porté sur la n20 guetta ils sont aussi à
toronto et nous ont montré à la
télévision
ils ont tous montré doit être plus d'un
tantôt je leur ai dit qu'il faut faire
attention parce qu'ils ne sont pas tous
des hommes d'honneur
[Musique]
le procureur vedette nicola gratteri est
un dieu qui a dirigé l'opération ciblant
la buanderie de siderno il critique lui
aussi sévèrement les autorités
canadiennes pour leur manque de
collaboration
norris a fait plus de dix ans que nous
disons aux canadiens de faire attention
parce que la haine brin guetta est très
présente au canada surtout à tort on
n'avait pas une bonne collaboration avec
la police canadiens
on nous a très peu écoutés mais
récemment la police canadienne semble
être davantage intéressée à ce que nous
leur disons ils sont davantage
conscients du problème de la drogue et à
l'ancien dirigeant de la grc dans la
lutte contre les crimes organisés en
ontario benz wav et admet que la police
canadienne c'est traîner davantage des
pieds dans la lutte anti-mafia en
ontario qu'au québec où beaucoup
d'argent a été dépensé dans l' enquête
colisée il y a des gens dans la police
qui ne comprennent pas comment
fonctionne le crime organisé des gens
qui pensent qu'on peut faire des
enquêtes durant un an et tout arrêté par
la suite parce que ça coûte trop cher
ils ne comprennent pas que le crime
organisé est d'implanter ici depuis
longtemps et que ça va continuer
longtemps
c'est là où la police échoue lorsqu'elle
ne comprend pas et crime organisé et ne
le prend pas au sérieux
un tel service celui qui a succédé à
benchoud avait kevin harrison admis au
toronto star que la police ontarienne a
négligé ces dernières années la
n'dranghetta que la priorité visaient
d'autres groupes du crime organisé
le grand patron de la lutte anti mafia
de la grc au canada l'inspecteur wayne
jacquard affirme que les choses ont été
rétablies il ya toujours quelque chose
qui peut être fait d'une façon meilleur
saut ou le vous mais s'est dit certain
temps les choses ont peu été comme leurs
aînés mais si les choses au modèle you
comme sur celle ci n'a mentionné
entraîné je suis sorti qu'hier
de fait la grc avait amorcé en 2008 une
grande enquête en ontario contre la
mafia
le projet hope & joe un peu après le
projet colisée au québec selon des
documents que radio-canada et le toronto
star ont obtenu cette enquête ciblait
une quinzaine de gros noms de la
n'dranghetta une trentaine de personnes
dites d'intérêt proche du crime organisé
mais cette enquête n'a duré qu'un an
elle a été abandonnée en 2009
monsieur jacquard ne veut pas dire
pourquoi il se limite à dire que
l'exercice n'a pas été vain même si
projet ou une opération cesse la
formation côté rue puis par cette
enquête le n'ai jamais appartenu
donc ça rende nos banques de données et
on continue on a fait l'analyse donc la
formation je m'aperçus en parcourant la
liste des différents suspects dans leur
quête op zhu de la grc écrit mines et
d'italie nous avons pu établir des liens
entre les individus ciblés et au moins
six compagnies de construction
ontarienne ce qui n'est pas sans
rajouter aux soupçons de l'infiltration
de la mafia d'un secteur de la
construction en ontario en profitent du
crime organisé parce qu'ils investissent
l'argent ça devient un problème
lorsqu'on trouve ça positif
six personnes se tirent dessus si
personne ne sonne l'alarmé
personne ne crie on appelle son député
pour se plaindre qu'ils se préoccupent
de leur investissement
c'est une question d'attitude il
empoisonne notre économie si une loi
anti association mafieuse
vous savez qu'au canada on en a pas ce
n'est pas possible
vous n'avez pas loi sur les associations
mafieuses
c'est pas sérieux n'est ce pas procès
plusieurs des personnes vivant au canada
que les autorités italiennes voudrait
extradé font face à des accusations en
vertu de la loi anti association
mafieuse
cette voix rend coupable quiconque
détient volontaire avec la mafia sans
qu'il ne soit nécessaire de connaître
directement un crime
contrairement au code tunnel canadien
il s'agit en quelque sorte d'une loi
d'exception qui sert d'outil principal
dans la guerre contre la mafia en italie
cette loi qui n'existe pas au canada ne
peut donc pas être utilisé pour extrader
quelqu'un si la mafia s'est installé à
toronto c'est parce que le système
législatif n'est pas très sévère et
c'est la même chose dans des pays de
l'europe du nord où il n'ya pas de lutte
contre la mafia parce que pour eux la
mafia n'existe pas c'est la même chose
au canada
les italiens ont-ils raison de critiquer
le laxisme des autorités canadiennes
wen jacquard et keaven harrison de la
grc affirme ne pas avoir reçu les
mandats de la police italienne pour
l'arrestation de jean liées à la
'ndrangheta en ontario que ces mandats
n'aurait vraisemblablement pas franchi
le processus d'extradition en raison du
fait que le canada n'a pas de loi anti
association mafieuse
est ce que vous comprenez la frustration
des italiens définitivement c'est je me
fais ce travail et de nos pays parce que
on a discuté que la loi est différente
de chaque pays on trouve à jouer à
l'intérieur de nos lois et pour
s'assurer qu'on protège les intérêts à
l'intérieu nos pays l'italie fait la
même chose
après la pause quand sicilien calabrais
font des affaires ensemble s'ils sont
pas dans le territoire d'origine
ils veulent pas créer des problèmes vont
se trouver d'accord il faut il faut se
ménager
[Musique]
au delà de la puissance de la
n'dranghetta de toronto tous se
demandent ce qui va arriver quand vito
rizutto sortira de prison dans les
prochains jours il n'est pas certain
qu'il doive viendra vivre à montréal où
son clan a été passablement affaibli au
cours des dernières années
nous poursuivons notre enquête nous
sommes en 2007
la police italienne découvre dans cette
maison de la calabre une cache lors
d'une perquisition
cette maison appartient à carmelo bruche
aisée un calabrais qui vit actuellement
à toronto
considéré comme un fugitif par la police
italienne qui le connaît bien
la police l'a même filmé en sortant de
la buanderie se trouvant dans le centre
commercial appartenant au chef du clan
de la 'ndrangheta a siderno des
transcriptions de conversations
téléphoniques datant de 2004 obtenu des
tribunaux italiens établissent que
carmelo bouche aisés qui était en
contacts d'affaires avec vito rizzuto
cinq jours plus tard résultat est arrêté
dans sa maison de luxe à montréal qui
sera extradé aux états unis où il est
condamné à dix ans de prison pour sa
participation à un triple meurtre commis
en 1981 pour le compte de la famille
mafieuse bonanno de new york
quelques heures après cette arrestation
francesco arcadi un lieutenant de régis
tôt calabrais communique avec couches
aisées qui est atterri tout sera résolu
sous peu qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
carmel montée de mézères qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire dans les jours qui suivent
carmel où boucher et quitte le canada
pour mille à l'est pendant plus de
quinze mois il va garder contact avec
les différents lieutenant de vito
rizzuto
qui est donc ce calabre est recherché
par la police italienne et qui vit
paisiblement à toronto
je concède lui c'est qu'il a été
acquitté en italie dans un procès
impliquant le clan rizzuto pour
blanchiment d'argent
mais depuis de nouvelles accusations ont
été portées contre lui pour association
mafieuse
bush aisée et décrits dans les documents
de l' enquête criminelle de la police
italienne comme participant à une
organisation criminelle complexe au
canada composé de plusieurs cellules
familiales calabraise et siciliennes
impliqués dans le trafic international
de drogue malgré tout son casier
judiciaire est vierge au canada ses
liens avec le clan rizzuto démontre la
proximité qui existe entre calabrais et
siciliens dans ce qu'il est temps de
faire des affaires que c'est une erreur
de poser systématiquement les clans
mafieux
le documentariste italien alberto nerfs
a tiny souligne qu'en amérique du nord
tout est en jeu qu'il n'y a pas de
territoire que des intérêts très grand
c'est l'europe sur le valway la mafia
ils sont deux
des gens qui s'y sont pas dans le
territoire d'origine
ils veulent pas créé les problèmes ils
doivent arriver il doit laisser
s'installer et et il faut être
silencieux il faut se trouver d'accord
il faut il faut se ménager au québec
l'organisation criminelle la plus
puissante et la cosa nostra
c'est une cosa nostra différentes que
celles en silence la cosa nostra
américaines et canadiennes est une
organisation qui n'acceptent pas que les
siciliens montréal à cosa nostra était
composé de tommy neil provenant de
différentes régions d'italie de la
calabre et de la syrie mais
l'arrestation de vito rizzuto en 2004 à
tout chambarder depuis les attentats ne
se comptent plus dans la métropole
les tueurs ont frappé jusqu'au sommet de
son clan avec le meurtre de son père
nicolo de son fils nick junior avec la
disparition de son bras droit par luanda
avec le meurtre de celui désigné par la
mafia de new york pour lui succéder
salvatore montagna qu'est ce qui va
ressortir de toute cette violence
même les enquêteurs anti mafia les plus
chevronnés ne peuvent le dire comme
pierrick vecchio de la police de
montréal qui a témoigné à la commission
charbonneau
on prend les calabre et on prend les
siciliens puis un jour ce sera peut-être
quelqu'un d'eau c'est comme je peux
faire l'analogie ce comme une forêt un
qu'un conte à des feuillus quand que ça
repousse ccc des conifères cassard icône
fatma ou alico sa peau sans feuillus
donc il ya un changement qui se fait le
net tout naturellement comme ça avec la
nouvelle génération de mafieux
assisterons-nous un changement de style
comme en italie à montréal là
la mafia les mafias italiennes un corps
un peu stéréotypé je pense tout le temps
passe et les mots ni funéraire de de
nick rizzuto par exemple c'est ça pour
moi c'était c'était une scène dans le
film de scorsese
et nos stations de de pouvoir de
richesse en italie on n'a pas ça les
mafieux mon pare d or comme ça parce que
il faut être dans l'ombre silencieux
plusieurs voix dans les attentats des
dernières années à montréal la signature
de la n'dranghetta de toronto mais selon
nos sources son rôle serait limité
malgré tout cet analyste de la grc qui a
témoigné à la commission charbonneau
pense que les calabrais dirige
actuellement la mafia montréalaise
je suis pas en train de dire que la
faction sicilienne est complètement
disparu par contre il ya un retour du
crime organisé d'origine calabraise qui
s'est fait suite à l'arrestation et à
l'extradition de monsieur vito rizutto
certains signes sur l' influence de la
n'dranghetta sur les événements de
montréal ne trompent pas notamment la
présence aux côtés de raynald desjardins
lors de son arrestation pour le meurtre
de montagne en 2011 de vittorio mirare
qui d'une famille calabraise établie en
ontario
desjardins pourtant été longtemps
associé ou s'essayait de vito rizzuto
dans la mafia
les alliances se font et se défont pour
notter antonio nicaso c'est l'occasion
ou jamais pour la n'dranghetta de
profiter de la situation géographique de
montréal qui en fait une plaque
tournante du crime organisé en amérique
du nord
celui qui contrôle montréal contrôler
son corps c'est le point d'entrée
principale pour le trafic des
stupéfiants destination de new york
je crois que la n'dranghetta à réaliser
l'importance stratégique du port de
montréal pour avoir accès au marché new
yorkais c'est réussissent à mettre la
main sur montréal
ils pourront contrôler les voies de
trafic de la cocaïne vers le marché de
drogue le plus important vito rizutto
pourra-t-il reprendre sa place lorsqu'il
reviendra au canada se rangera t-il
derrière les calabrais s'associera t-il
à la n'dranghetta en allant vivre à
toronto comme le pensent certaines
sources policières difficile à dire mais
quoi qu'il fasse il ne faut pas le
compter pour battu toutes les rides du
tout avait la capacité d'investir les
sommes colossales pour construire le
pont et les siens de faire des affaires
aux philippines d'investir en suisse il
concevait le marché de façon globale on
sous-estiment ses jambes en plus bien
sûr pour atteindre leur but ils ont
besoin d'entretenir des liens avec des
gens qui n'ont rien à se reprocher mais
il ne faut jamais sous-estimer les
criminels ce sont des criminels de
première classe
quoi qu'il advienne une chose est claire
pour ceux qui luttent contre la mafia
la pire erreur que nous gouvernement
pourrait faire serait de sous-estimer la
capacité d'adaptation de la mafia en
calabre le procureur gars thierry
n'hésite pas à lancer cet avertissement
même si la situation au canada est loin
d'être aussi dramatique que dans le sud
de l'italie
qu'est ce qui va se passer si on prend
pas ce problème au sérieux dans sept ou
huit ans vous aurez les mêmes problèmes
que la haine drogué tas sera plus
présente et donc ça veut dire moins
démocratie s'impose marché moins nous
aurons de liberté pour faire nos propres
choix
il ne faut pas penser qu'ils peuvent
uniquement acheter des restaurants des
hôtels des supermarchés
il pourrait prendre le contrôle des
journaux ou même des chaînes de
télévision pour contrôler l'information
ça c'est l'ultime étape de la mafia des
papiers
[Musique]
quand vito rizutto sera libéré de sa
prison du colorado il sera libre comme
l'air mais devra quitter immédiatement
le territoire américain pour le canada
pour l'instant aucune demande
d'extradition n'a été formulée par la
justice italienne
si vous voulez nous contacter consultez
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
vous pouvez faire vos commentaires et
vos suggestions et revoir le reportage
pour connaître notre démarche
journalistique je vous invite à
consulter mon blogue
veuillez prendre note qu'en quête et
rediffusée le dimanche à 18 heures sur
le réseau d'information
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine enquête le mystère
sur les causes de la mort des deux
soeurs bélanger en thaïlande
regardez l'écart cinq jours sans voulons
leur donner aux autorités aux autorités
canadiennes se sont cachés quelque chose
c'est cacher quelque chose ou à ce que
[Musique]
j'essaie d'avoir été là bonsoir et la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]